- I thought it said
"king crap" for a second.
I was like, "Well I know what that is.
"That's a giant (bleep)."
(upbeat music)
- I'm kind of excited 'cause
I'm a big fan of K-pop.
- Is it kind of like in K-pop songs
they start singing in
English and in Korean?
- It's a language from
the Congo, am I right?
- I did not know any of
these 'cause I am not Korean,
as many of you guys don't know.
- Skinship.
- It makes me immediately think of pork.
Maybe you're saying
someone looks like a pig?
- A friend you have a relationship with
that you give 'em some skin a lot?
- It's a relationship that
you have with your skin,
the way that you treat your skin,
the way you care for your skin.
- When you ship skins, dry
skin, moist skin, done.
- How far did you get into skinship?
I might actually take that
into my own vocabulary.
- King-car, king sized car.
- Like, "Oh dope, your car is a king-car."
- King Kong, this is the giant monkey
that takes over New York City.
King, no, that's not true.
- Can I call people that?
Will Korean people be like,
"Ooh, this girl knows
all about our stuff."
- Now I have a new pickup line.
"Hey, you're a king-car."
- Sel-ca, self care.
- Science and Engineering
Library in California, yes?
- Sel-ca, like a selfie?
(bell dings)
I kinda like that better than selfie.
- SNS.
- Sounds like something dirty and sexual.
- Solid, no sleeves. (laughs)
- Say no, sir.
- SNSD is a popular Korean pop band.
- So not sorry.
Bam!
- Oh, I'm gonna hit you up on that SNS.
- CF, care forever.
- Is this a K-pop group?
- Okay, so we have AF.
I'm tired, CF, 'cause (bleep).
I'm tired 'cause (bleep).
- Clown face.
- Chubby friend?
- So I would be like,
"Oh, have you seen that CF
"with the girl eating the apple sauce?"
- Apart.
- Apartheid? (laughs)
- "How much of a distance
is there between you?"
Or, "You were torn apart."
- How is the Korean accent?
- [Man Off Screen] Apart.
- Apart, apartment.
(bell dings)
Boom!
- "We're going back to my apart, girl.
"I'm gonna show you how I live."
- Fighting.
- Is it like fighting the
urge to do something bad?
- Let's start a fight.
- I know this one, 'cause
I watch a lot of K-drama.
- Fighting, it just means like
in Chinese it's like di yo,
"Go, let's do this!
(bell dings)
K-dramas, man, they get your heart.
They make you want to say, "Fighting!"
- These were kind of fun.
I really wanna adopt some of
these into my own vernacular.
- Fighting is the best word,
'cause it's encouragement.
Anybody can use it.
It's English, it's Korean, it's Konglish.
- I also like skinship, 'cause
it's what I'd like to do
with all of the king-cars of the world.
- I'm going to invite them to my apart.
We're gonna take a self cam.
We're gonna add each other on our SNSes,
and everything is gonna be great.